- And I am, my name is Mats Lanner.
I'm the director of engineering for ECS,
so responsible for all
things ECS and related.
With me I have Alexandr.
- Hey folks, I'm Alex.
I'm a product manager for
Amazon ECS focusing on Fargate.
- And we also our
distinguished guest. Yeah.
- Hi Reuben, quantitative
technologies at QRT.
Nice to meet you.
- Cool. So today we're gonna
talk a little bit about
what Amazon ECS is or it works.
This is a 300 session,
so we assume that you
know the basics of ECS
since you chose to join us.
Then I'm gonna talk about
capacity provisioning with ECS,
how you get the compute,
you need to actually
run your applications.
After that, Alexandr will take over
and talk about security
and compliance aspects
of running your applications on ECS
and how we help you there.
And also cost optimization,
what we do to make it cheaper for you
to run your applications.
And then perhaps most interestingly,
we'll have Ruben talk about the journey
that cube research and
technologies have been on ECS,
going from a reasonable scale application
to a very large scale
workload on ECS and Fargate
just been super exciting to see.
So what is ECS?
The simplest way of
thinking about it is that,
ECS is a container orchestrator built
for use on AWS,
where the guiding principle is that
we take on as much of the
operational chores as possible
so that you can focus on
your application instead.
There's no control plane to manage
because we take care of that.
If you use Fargate, there's
no compute to manage
because we take care of things like that.
So looking at ECS,
there are four pillars we think about
for how ECS works and
what we build it for.
So the first one is that,
it's to launch containers at scale.
It doesn't matter if your
workload requires one task
and runs at a fraction of a TPS
or if it's a very large scale application
with tens of thousands of tasks
running at the hundreds
of thousands of TPS.
ECS is there to support
you on that whole journey,
giving you a consistent operating model
regardless of what your scale is.
Second is that you only
pay for what you use.
And what that means is that
there's no charge for using ECS itself.
What you do pay for
is the resources that
we provision for you.
So if you launch EC2 instances,
well you pay for the EC2
instances, EBS volumes,
low balancers and things like that.
But you only pay for the things that
you actually need to run your application.
If you're using Fargate, for example,
if you're not running a task,
there's no charge for Fargate, right?
You only charge while
you run Fargate tasks.
Going back to what I mentioned earlier,
we're all about improving
speed and agility for you all.
We want you to be able to
focus on your application,
be able to reach scale
and production with your
application as fast as possible,
and not have to fiddle
with a bunch of infrastructure mechanisms.
That doesn't mean that we lock you down,
so that you can't do advanced scenarios,
but the default experience
is to get you up and running
with AWS best practices.
And then when your use case requires it,
you can dig into more
advanced capabilities
and take advantage of those.
And finally, as I mentioned
a little bit earlier,
we embody AWS security
and operational best practices in AWS,
we try to set you up for success.
Part of that is that if you
use things like Fargate,
you don't have to worry about
how correctly configure an
instance to run your workload.
We take care of all of that.
With Fargate, you get task isolation.
So every task you run,
runs in its own EC2 instance.
And in EC2 instance
that is never reused it.
It's only used for the lifecycle the task,
and then it's recycled.
And to give a little
bit of context about ECS
and how ECS is growing,
so as of about two months ago,
customers launched about 3
billion tasks on ECS every week.
That's across all of our regions.
And looking at new
customers who come to AWS,
start running new workloads
and choose to use containers
to run those workloads,
we see about 65% of those
customers choose to use ECS.
And the vast majority of them
choose to use Fargate with ECS,
'cause it just makes their life easier.
Additionally, a lot of
Amazon also runs on ECS,
both AWS services and
Amazon.com services run on ECS.
And one specific example that
we can share here is that,
during Prime Day this past summer,
the team supporting Prime Day
launched about 18 million
tasks on Fargate every day
during Prime Day.
Which doesn't quite include
everything they launched
leading up to Prime Day, but still.
So it is an indication of Fargate and ECS
is ready to support the
biggest workloads out there.
So why do customers choose to use ECS
and trust ECS to run their applications?
Part of this simplicity,
not simplicity in the
sense that ECS is limited
and only gives you a
limited set of capabilities,
but simple because it simplifies
operations for customers.
As I've said a few times now,
we really want to focus our effort
to help you focus on your application.
We'll take care of the other
operational chores for you.
Other thing is secure,
obviously we all want that.
So we make use of AWS
security best practices.
We set you up for success
with that from the beginning
without you having to do
anything explicit about it.
And finally, efficiency.
So we're very focused on driving
high utilization for you,
so that you can run your
application at scale
with high availability at the
lowest possible cost to you.
And we do that in a number of ways.
So for example, with Fargate,
you tell us that you need a two vCPU task
with eight gigs of memory.
Well that's what we provisioned for you
and that's what you pay for.
If there's any overhead
on our end on that,
that's our problem to
solve, not your problem.
You tell us you want two
vCPUs, we give you two vCPUs.
All kinds of things like that we do,
including scaling up when
you need to scale up,
scale down when you need to scale down,
things like that that will make it easier
and lower cost for you to
operate your applications.
So digging in a little bit
into capacity provisioning.
So how do you get the compute you need
to actually run your application tasks?
I'm not gonna go through
everything in this slide,
but I do want to give the context of
AWS provides a wide range
of compute options, right?
And at the end of the day,
most of it relies on EC2
in one way or another.
The exception would be
if you use ECS anywhere
and you're run on premises,
in which case you're on the hook
for providing the actual compute.
But you can use ECS to run
across all of these options,
you get a consistent operating model.
But we also see that the vast
majority of our customers
use either EC2 or the use Fargate.
So I'll dig in a little
bit to what trade-offs
and benefits are between
using Fargate and EC2.
So Fargate, which many of
you're probably familiar with,
provides a fully managed
data plane for you.
We abstract away the
compute to the point where
the only thing you need to think about
is the amount of vCPUs
and the amount of memory that you need.
There are a few other things
that you can control as well,
you can request more storage
and things like that.
But centrally it's CPU
and memory that you think about.
So we take care of everything else, right?
If you need to launch two tasks,
we'll provide a compute
that you can run two tasks.
If you need to run 500 tasks,
we'll provide that compute.
We take care of providing
workload isolation
by design in Fargate,
as I mentioned earlier,
every task runs on a
separate EC2 instance.
That EC2 instance is
provisioned for that task.
When the task stops, we
throw away the EC2 instance.
So every time you launch a task,
you know that I'm running
on a fresh compute.
There's nothing left from previous tasks
or anything like that.
There can be no task crosstalk
or anything like that,
which for many customers is
a key feature in Fargate.
And I mentioned already about
how you only pay for Fargate tasks
when they're running, right?
As soon as the Fargate task stops,
there's no more charge for it.
So you get a lot of benefits with Fargate,
but you also give up control of things.
So if you choose to use
Amazon EC2 as you compute,
you get a lot of control.
You get to choose exactly
which EC2 instance types
and sizes you use for your application.
Whereas with Fargate we use
a wide range of application,
or sorry, instance types
and sizes for your tasks.
Depending on region, depending
on availability zone,
you may see us use say an M8I for a task
versus an M6I,
depending on availability.
We always focus on being able
to launch customer tasks,
prioritizing that over consistency
in the underlying compute,
which is an important aspect of Fargate.
For EC2, you control all of that.
But that comes with a cost,
'cause now you're also on the
hook for providing the army
that we use for EC2 instance.
So you have to make sure that that army
and that instance is correctly
and securely configured.
You need to make sure that
you patch your instances
that's on you to take care of.
But on the other hand, you
do get to take advantage
of all the EC2 purchasing models.
You can use reserve instances,
you can use on demand
capacitor reservations,
instant savings plans,
things of that nature.
Both Fargate and EC2 supports
the compute savings plan.
So you do have that option
available regardless.
So there are few tensions
between using Fargate and EC2
and we've had lots of
feedback from customers
telling us that, you know,
we love Fargate, we need
a little bit more control
for our workloads.
So in response to that,
we launched ECS Managed
Instances about two months ago.
And what we're trying to do
here is strike the right balance
between managed compute
that we give with Fargate
versus giving you all more control
over what we use to run your workloads.
So a couple of key differences is that
with ECS Managed Instances,
we launched EC2 instances in your account.
So you will see these EC2 instances
but you have no control over them.
You can't take any mutating
actions on these instances,
only we can do that for you.
But that also means that
we control the entire life
cycle of these instances.
We make sure that we launch
them when they're needed
because you need more compute capacity
to run your applications.
We make sure that after roughly two weeks,
which is very similar
to how Fargate operates,
we will retire the instance
and we will shift your toss
over to a new instance.
And we do this that we
can patch your instances
and make sure that we
always meet patching SLAs.
You have control over the instance types.
So you can either choose
to say no AWS, I trust you,
pick the most cost
optimized instance types
from my application.
Or you can say that, no, I
know exactly what I need.
I need network optimized
Graviton instances
from my workload.
And you can choose to
use that or you can say,
hey, I want GPUs for my workload.
You can get those with
ECS Managed Instances.
We have a more robust cost optimization
in ECS Managed Instances.
So one is that we've rebuilt
how we scale up additional
compute for you.
So we can scale up
additional compute faster
with ECS Managed Instances
than we can with both Fargate and EC2.
But we also implemented cost optimization
that continuously looks for idle instances
or underutilized instances.
And when we find underutilized instances,
we will shift tasks
over to other instances
and then be able to shut
down those instances
and reducing your costs as a result.
And finally we give you more control.
So many of you who are
Fargate customers today
will know that you can't
run privileged containers
on Fargate, right?
You can't make use of agents
that use eBPF for example.
With managed instances,
we give you this ability.
By default, nothing runs as privilege,
but you can say in your trust definition,
Hey I have this sidecar container,
it needs privileged access
because it requires eBPF
and you can do that.
So going back to the earlier slide,
where does managed instances
fit into the picture?
So it's right in between Fargate and EC2,
you get more capabilities.
We still give you a fully
managed compute experience,
but you need to be more aware of that.
We actually provision
EC2 instances for you
even though we completely
manage them on your behalf.
So a core concept in ECS
is capacity providers.
We introduced this back in 2019
and originally we had the
Fargate capacity provider,
which is actually two capacity providers,
the Fargate on demand and Fargate Spot.
And we introduced auto scaling
group capacity provider
for EC2 use.
So with managed instances,
we've introduced a new capacity provider
that works closely with
the whole task life cycle
in ECS to make sure that
you have instances available to you
when you need them and
only when you need them.
So looking at the Fargate
capacity provider,
as I mentioned before, it's simple, right?
You don't have to worry
about EC2 instances.
You need not worry about configuration,
patching, anything like that.
When your workload increases
and you need more tasks
to run your application,
we will launch more tasks for you.
When your workload decreases,
we will scale down those tasks.
And all you need to think about,
as I mentioned before,
is the amount of CPU
and the amount of memory that you need.
For managed instances,
I touched on some of these things already.
So this new capacity provider
is tightly integrated
with the rest of ECS to know
when it needs to launch
additional EC2 instances
and when it should shut
down EC2 instances.
We launched these
instances in your account
but they're fully managed by us.
You can see them but you
can't terminate them,
you can't take any
mutating actions on them.
And we control everything about
the management of these instances.
So for example,
we provide the army used
for these instances,
you cannot control that.
We use Bottlerocket as our
container operating system,
'cause we think it's the
right Linux OS to use
for container workloads.
We make sure it's configured correctly
and as I mentioned,
we run for about two weeks
and then we replace instances,
shifting your workloads transparently.
One thing that you get
with ECS Managed Instances
is that you get to use EC2 event windows.
So if you want to control when
we replace your instances,
you can create EC2 event windows
and tell us, hey, use
this four hour time window
on Sunday mornings between
1:00 AM and 5:00 AM
and we'll make sure that
we only initiate operations
in that event window.
So with these assess managed instances,
you have the option to
map the instance type
to your workload needs, right?
So you can use the
default capacity provider,
then you don't have to do anything
other than just selecting it
and trust us to pick
the right instance types
and we'll focus on cost when
we make those decisions.
Obviously the tasks you run also matter.
We try to bend pack tasks
onto multiple tasks on an instance,
so we'll take that into
consideration as well.
But when you want to
explore more capabilities,
you can use the custom capacity provider
and then you get to use
what we call attribute based
instance type selection.
So you can define things like,
hey, I need a GPU,
I need a GPU of this particular type.
I need at least this number
of vCPUs on the instance.
I need it to be network optimized.
Any number of attributes
like that you can control.
So you don't have to pick
specific instance types,
although you can if you really want to,
instead focus on the
attributes of these instances
that map to what you
need for your workload.
So now we have EC2, we have Fargate
and we have managed instances.
So when should you use these?
So we strongly recommend that
if you're using ECS on EC2 today,
you should go take a
look at managed instances
because we think we can give
you much better experience
using managed instances.
For Fargate,
Fargate is the default in ECS today.
It will remain the default
because we think that
is the best experience
for the most customers.
That said, if you're on Fargate today
and you run into limitations on Fargate,
then managed instances
is there to support you.
So for example, if you
need to run a 48 BCPU task,
well Fargate does not support that,
but managed instances does.
If you want to use a logging side card
that requires eBPF,
well Fargate does not support that,
but managed instances does.
If you want to be one of the cool kids
and use a GPU workload,
well Fargate does not support that,
but managed instances does.
So those are the kind of things
that you should think about
when you want to use managed instances.
And with that I'm gonna
hand over to Alexandr
who's gonna talk about
security and compliance.
- Well thank you Matt.
Security and compliance,
what an exciting topic, right?
So let's try to make it
more or less painless.
When we talk about security,
we usually start with looking at
the shared responsibility model.
And let's take a look at
the screens right now.
That's the situation with
ECS and self-managed EC2.
Well, AWS is responsible of course
for the ECS control plane.
It is responsible for all
the foundational services,
storage compute network and all monitoring
and of course the global infrastructure,
basically regions, local zones,
everything that is actually physical.
But you have to worry about
and secure all your compute capacity.
You need to think about how
to provision that capacity,
how to scale it up and down,
how to distribute it across
different availability zones.
You need to think about instant selection
and more than that, each
time you launch an instance,
you need to place the right army.
You need to make sure that
it has the right version of the agent,
you need to patch it
and of course you need to keep
monitoring all that stuff.
On top of that, your application runs,
yet another layer of complexity.
So that becomes rather
complicated I would say.
That's why with Fargate
and now with ECS Managed Instances,
AWS takes on more responsibilities.
So you don't need to worry about things
that you worried about
with self-managed stuff.
Things like capacity
provisioning and EC2 instances.
Everything that runs on them,
it's fully managed by
AWS in different ways
and I'm gonna talk about it in a minute.
So the key point is that
you're still responsible
for your application.
How the load balancing happens,
how the security groups are configured.
So you can configure security groups,
define firewall rules
and of course IAM roles.
So basically this is your responsibility,
Everything else is AWS.
So as you can imagine
that change in this shared
responsibility model
gives you way more time to
focus on what actually matters
to your business on
building the application,
building the business logic,
serving your customers
while AWS takes care of
pretty much the infrastructure
and configuration.
Now let's take a look at
the isolation boundaries
and that's where we have a
difference between Fargate
and ECS managed instances.
As Mats already mentioned,
Fargate provides a really
strong isolation boundary
security model.
Each task is launched on
an separate EC2 instance
hidden in AWS account
and we do not reuse these tasks.
So we never place two
tasks in the same instance.
We never reuse the same
instance for two tasks in a row,
we always discarded scrap the memory,
scrap the ephemeral storage.
So there is absolutely no risk
of data cross contamination.
With managed instances,
we launch EC2 instances in your accounts
and we do believe it's
the best option for you
to actually launch multiple tasks.
So we take care about of beam packing
to optimize the infrastructure,
to optimize the utilization.
So with that approach
we can probably launch
more tasks on less compute
and really help you reduce your AWS build.
And of course you have controls there,
if you're not okay with launching,
say tasks from different applications
on the same instance,
you can use different capacity providers.
So you don't, you have
certain controls there
and of course you can control
the size of your instances
to pretty much simulate
this single task experience.
But we will keep reusing,
we will keep these
instances running for longer
after they become it idle.
For a very short period of time,
it is now configurable.
You can actually set it up to one hour,
so we don't just release
that capacity. Why?
Well because each next
task that is launched
on an already running instance
launches way faster,
like three times faster
than a task on a brand new instance
when we have to spin it up.
So you have these controls
with managed instances.
Let's take a look at the best practices
that we use with Fargate.
And they're very similar between Fargate
and managed instances.
Well except for the isolation point,
task isolation is a key,
probably the key feature of Fargate.
We do reduce the attack surface,
so we don't have access
to underlying OS hardware.
You don't have access,
we don't really have access to that.
So we have access only to
logs that are important
for telemetry for troubleshooting,
but we don't have access
and we don't give you access
to underlying hardware.
We do run regular patching.
And one very important thing
that is often overlooked,
AWS VPC networking mode.
Why it's so important?
Well because now you can,
each task gets an individual IP address
and with that you can use VPC flow logs
to understand what's going
on with your traffic.
You can use security groups
to have fine grain control
for each individual task.
So you have really full control
over your network security
and that's a major thing.
Something that you cannot achieve
with network address translation.
If you're running for example,
bridge mode with ECS EC2,
you can't really do that.
So it's a really strong
and very secure solution
that follows pretty much all
AWS security best practices.
Managed instances,
look at the list of benefits,
fully managed compute,
compliance and patching every two weeks.
So if you tell me it looks like Fargate
that is launched,
launches instances in your
accounts, you won't be wrong.
Technically this is Fargate that
is exposed to your accounts.
You're getting the same experience
with a couple of differences.
Well, Bottlerocket, as Mats mentioned,
it's a new OS that is developed by AWS.
It's an open source project
that we believe is the best way
to run containerized workloads.
It has a very minimal
set of packages required
for containerized workloads.
We don't have anything extra
resulting in a reduced attack surface.
And of course all the instances
that we launch in your accounts,
you don't have access to them.
You can still see them.
Why you still see them?
Well I can give you an example.
Imagine if you don't see them and then,
but they already exist
and run in your account
and then you have to go and
for example, delete a subnet.
What's gonna happen?
You're gonna get an STRN message saying,
hey, you have instances running
so you'd better see them.
So you have visibility
but you don't have control,
you don't have a way to change them
directly using key EC2 APIs.
Again, everything goes through the ECS API
and added layer of security.
And of course Mats already
talked about event windows.
It's really neat feature.
Your EC2 instances have to go
through hardware replacement
from time to time, et cetera.
So you can define this windows.
Now you can use the same concept
to tell us when you
are okay with patching.
So it's not going to
happen on a random day,
is gonna happen in the interval time
interval that you tell us too.
Well compliance,
really short.
Fargate and managed
instances really help you
achieve better compliance faster
because now you can point to AWS and say,
hey, AWS takes care of
pretty much everything
but my application.
And now to achieve compliance,
you need to provide a much,
much shorter list of evidences
that you actually have meet
these compliance requirements.
Everything else is on AWS.
So we have all this list of things
that we provide as an evidence
that we actually meet the
compliance requirements.
So we help your workloads
achieve compliance faster.
And of course you can
find the list of services
and scope if you go to that page.
It's a really neat website.
Pretty much everything you can find there,
Amazon is yes, will be there.
So compliance is a great topic,
but now let's chat about something
that is very dear to my heart,
how to save money, running
workloads on Amazon ECS.
And of course we're gonna talk about
cost optimization strategies.
Four things, choosing the right hardware,
choosing the purchasing options
that work best for your workloads.
Figuring out how to scale
and optimize your workloads
and of course observing it
and making sure that
actually all that works to your benefit.
Starting with hardware we have,
today we offer the AWS
S3 different CPU options,
Intel CPUs, AMD, and Graviton.
And of course with Fargate
you have controlled whether
you want to use X86, 64
or ARM CPUs.
So Gravitons or ARM.
So that's your control.
But you can't really choose
whether your tasks will land on
Intel or AMG.
And what if your application
takes a dependency on
AVX five 12, for example, instruction sets
that work really well on Intel.
Or what if your application
benefits from a super strong
single core performance of AMD CPUs?
Well, that's where managed
instances come to play.
You can choose the CPU type,
you can choose exact instance types
that are the best for your compute.
And guess what?
If you run something like tasks,
tasks that are jobs, time bound jobs,
if you finish your work
running your workloads faster,
you pay less.
So it's an excellent way
to choose the right CPU
for your workload to actually pay less
or just get the latest Graviton generation
with just phenomenal price
to performance ratio.
Switching to purchasing options on demand,
that's the default.
Excellent for spiky workloads.
The most expensive saving plans
when it comes to predictable workloads.
And if you can commit to spending
a certain amount of
money on AWS over a year
or three years,
you can get significant
discounts with that.
So if you have predictable workloads,
please, please, please use saving plans.
It's a very powerful tool
that you have in your arsenal,
something that you can use.
And on top of that Spot,
Spot is a great way if you to save,
if you have fault tolerant applications,
80% savings on compute easily.
Well with a caveat that we
can reclaim this capacity
at any time.
So really for fault tolerant applications,
this is actually something
that is not available
with managed instances yet.
Let's take a look at Fargate
and how Fargate helps you optimize costs.
So first of all, not really obvious,
but you always get a
hundred percent utilization.
Matt talked about it,
but we give you exactly
what you asked for.
You don't need to reason
about being packing your tasks
on that instance and figuring out
what happens when the task goes away,
what to do with that empty
slot on the instance,
what helps to place there.
Another thing that is really important,
you can speed up the
task launches on Fargate
with Seekable OCI, lazy loading,
the easier that we get the container
and we started before it's fully loaded.
It's an excellent feature.
Please, please, please use it,
it works better with large images.
And of course we have compute optimizer.
Now it looks at your workload and says,
by the way, you can stop these instances,
you're not using them
or it's better to right size
and just it suggests a better size.
If you for example,
run them at very low level
of CPU usage (indistinct)
go down the size, you don't
need that much capacity,
saving you money.
On managed instances,
the situation is slightly different.
Remember multiple tasks,
there's be packing problem.
What do we do with empty slots?
Well now we actively fill them.
We look at your entire cluster,
we find an unutilized instances
and we compact your tasks to better,
to achieve better utilization.
And we shut down stuff that recital,
which is really powerful
active optimization
that goes on all the time.
You can tell us, nope, I don't want that.
This particular tasks need
to run for a long time,
I cannot interrupt that, we have this way.
And you can actually disable
this feature completely,
which is handy when you use something
like reserved instances
and on demand capacity reservations.
You already paid for that hardware,
you already paid for that stuff.
Like why do you want
to stop this instances?
Maybe you want to keep
them running all the time,
so you can launch new tasks faster.
So there are different
ways to think about it.
And of course,
since we have multiple
tasks on a single instance,
now we can use container image cache.
So instead of downloading
the container image
from ECR every time,
your tasks can just grab it
from that instance immediately.
So to wrap up, you need
to think about Fargate
and manage instances.
And again, we believe that
Fargate is an excellent choice
for the majority of workloads,
but managed instances
come incredibly handy
when you need things like,
stuff that just does not work on Fargate.
eBPF is one example of that.
Another one is related to cost.
When you have short-lived
tasks on Fargate,
I'm sorry, it is not efficient.
You're spending way too much money,
'cause you're paying for the time,
the images being downloaded from ECR.
Managed instances,
as I said, contain rematch cache
and the ability to reuse
instances for new tasks,
it helps you save money.
So everything that runs 102 minutes,
I'm confident it's gonna
be way more cost optimal
on managed instances.
Please consider that as an option.
And of course if you have
your reserved instances,
or you have instance saving plans,
or DCR managed instances is a simple way
to use that capacity
and again, save money with ECS.
Well, with that, we're coming
to the most exciting part
of this presentation.
Ruben, please come on stage
and chat about QRT journey.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much, Alex. Thanks Mats.
Hello. Hello.
Let's wait. Okay, we have it.
Hello, I hope you're getting the best
of the first day of the re:Invent.
My name is Ruben
and before like diving into the journey
into the technical talk,
I would like to introduce
myself a little bit.
The first thing you need
to know about me is that
I'm Italian and that's
important for one reason.
I have a challenge with myself today
to try to deliver at least half
of the volume of information
I can do with my hands by using words.
So you're gonna let me know if
that works at the end of the presentation.
And the second element is,
I would like to talk
about my previous life
before selling my soul to finance.
I was actually a rocket scientist,
like I have a PhD in applied mathematics
and I was simulating rocketed engines.
I must admit I don't regret
the choice to switch,
but sometimes I miss the random explosion
in the lab sometimes.
What is QRT?
After introduction by myself,
I would like to talk about QRT.
Qube Research and Technologies
is a global systematic asset manager.
Let's dissect that a little
bit in the right order,
which means starting from the end.
Asset manager means we get
money from our investor.
So, and we put it on the market
to make more money with it.
By systematic what we mean is,
the vast majority of our
investment strategies are
data-driven and automatic.
So we have a lot of algorithms
which trade on the market
in a daily basis in an automated way.
By global means that QRT is
operating across the globe
and across all the type of assets.
Equity is futures, crypto, you name it.
And what's the mission purity?
Yeah, I already introduced
it a little bit,
but it's to deliver results
for our investor in our market condition.
Is it to understand when
market go is bullish
and it goes well, we want to do better.
And when things are less,
well then we try to mitigate that.
All right, start.
We are good with introductions
now we wanna dive into the nerdy talk.
When I joined QRT almost four years ago,
there was already an
existing solution in place
and it worked more or less like that.
We have researchers,
researchers are basically
the bright people
which come up with ideas for
investment strategies, right?
Most of them, especially in recent times,
they're used to use,
I mean they're used to do
their research with Python
because of, you know, the
rich data science ecosystem
or scientific computing.
So they were used to do
their research with Python
and then they had
somehow basically pair up
with the quantitative developer
and basically rewrite the
research in another language,
compile that artifact,
and then deploy it on an
existing on-prem infrastructure,
sharing resources with other type,
with other ideas, let's say.
I mean that worked pretty,
pretty, pretty well.
I mean, RT has been a
successful enterprise.
But when I joined,
we were tasked with
another task basically was,
which was let's try to build something
which is natively
scalable and cloud native.
So what we said is, okay,
maybe we can skip the detour,
let's keep what works.
Researchers really like to work in Python,
let's keep them working in Python.
And then what we decide to do
is containerize our Python workloads.
Okay, now we have our container
and we had to decide
which kind of orchestration
system we wanted to use,
I guess the fact that on this
sage is probably a spoiler,
but we ended up using Fargate and ECS.
Why?
I will try to explain you
why we chose Fargate as a
capacity provider in ECS
and as an orchestrator.
First of all, at that time
we were a very small team.
We were four when I joined
and we wanted to focus on the business.
The team was not particularly
expert in cloud computing,
but we were, I mean we had expertise
in the financial part and the
standard engineering part.
So we wanted to focus on our business.
Fargate gave us that serverless vision,
which made us focus on our core business.
We tend to build things within the team,
keeping the intellectual
impedance at the lowest we can.
And again, Fargate really
helps you with that.
At that time when we started our endeavor,
we didn't know if it would've
been successful or not.
So we were looking for
something which could help us
start small but scale if we need it.
And if we needed,
we needed the capacity to
keep up with our growth.
Last but not least,
I mean financial industry is
a very regulated industry,
so we needed a by default
compliant security posture.
And the fact that in Fargate you can,
everything is isolated, is encrypted,
you cannot assess it in your machine,
I mean that really played well for us.
So these were the design
principles of our choice.
Now let me try to explain
how things work a little
bit more in details.
Some schematic here, just
bear with me a little bit.
In our system we have
two type of services.
One type of services is called,
we call it quant computational unit
or compute units, QCUs
that you see here on
the bottom of the slide.
And then we have another type of service,
which is kind of a server that here
is marked logical server.
We also call it head node.
The role of the head node,
basically the QCs cannot talk.
And then we have as you see
in the top of the slide,
then we have our, you know,
underlying firm wise
database told the data.
Basically the QCUs are
designed to not talk directly
to the database for performance reason.
So the role of the head node is twofold.
One is to aggregate requests.
So imagine one of your units needs,
I don't know, Amazon prices for the stock
for the last 10 years
and another one needs it
for the last five years.
Basically the hand node
queries the database
for just 10 years and then
it does the slicing locally.
And the second one, as you
can imagine is caching.
We cache some of the requests in memory.
I talked about the fact that
this is a logical server. Why?
Because in reality our
head node deployment
is composed by several ECS services.
Actually in the bigger deployments,
several hundreds or
even several thousands,
in this slide, each
square is an ECS service.
And one particularity of this is that,
each service has one task, only one task.
This is a bit exotic with respect
to the best practices AWS recommends
while you have that again simplicity,
if you have two units basically publishing
almost the same thing,
then you need to decide
which one is the right one.
We decided to accommodate
a little bit of like,
of less residency for simplicity.
So they we're just one unit publishing.
All right, and another
important element here is
everything talks data
driven gRPC protocol.
So the QCU talks, gRPC to the head node,
which talks to gRPC to the shards
and the shards talk gRPC with database.
The shards here mean that obviously
you cannot host the entire data
you need in a single service.
So basically the shards split this data
based on several criteria
to have and to have a
distributed deployment.
Then as I told, like the QCUs then,
when they finish elaborating
what they need to elaborate,
they will publish the results
of their computation
back into our database.
Another important element here
is that service discovery.
In our experience when we tried
other orchestrating systems,
we realized that scaling DNS correctly
is kind of challenging.
So here we decided to use
cloud map, which is again,
serverless and we basically,
when we deploy the head nodes,
we register DNS entry in cloud map
and that's it works trademark.
All right, how did it go?
I guess again, the fact I'm on this stage
is probably a spoiler,
but it went very well.
I would like to promise you, you know,
to give you the reality things like,
the scale we are at,
unfortunately the compliance colleagues,
they hide in shadows.
So I cannot tell, I cannot
tell you the exact figures,
but we had hundred X growth,
which means everything and nothing.
What I can tell you is that
we have right now deployed
several tens of thousands of
services currently running
where the several tens of
thousands is on the higher range
of the tens of thousands.
That's the word I could
negotiate, I could tell you.
But based on the, you know,
the schematic I just presented,
you I mean,
you start facing some challenges
when you begin to scale.
For example, quotas on the
number of service per cluster,
number of CPUs per account,
et cetera, et cetera.
So actually we had to
evolve our deployment.
We actually tag team with AWS
with a process engagement that
we ended up with an evolution
of the architecture just presented,
which is the following one.
We already talked about head nodes,
we started to put head
nodes in dedicated accounts.
So we have some accounts for hand nodes,
some accounts for the QCUs.
All these accounts then
are within the same VPC,
which is stretched
across all the accounts.
A few caveats here.
When you do this,
you need to first define
the VPC in a single account
and then when you did that,
then you can stretch it.
Which means a couple of things,
the most important one is,
you can define, you can register
your DNS service discovery
only on the accounts
where you have defined,
you have created the VPC initially
and which means in our case
we created the VPC in
the head nodes accounts
because the head nodes are
the thing we want to discover.
The QCUs want to discover and
then you stretch their arm.
If you wanna use API based
or not DNS query based,
but API based service discovery,
that works across the
VPC without any problem.
Second important element,
and this is really the secret
sauce to become a success,
a successful asset manager,
like systematic asset manager
is the naming system for the clusters.
As you can see here, we're using flowers.
It's really, really the secret
sauce for our deployment.
We recommend you to do
that, it's great, it's fun.
All right, let's make a lead pose.
A lot of diagrams of schematic,
I mean, we grew from few services
in a single account, single cluster,
single account, multi cluster,
which I didn't show.
And now we are multi
account, multi cluster.
You can realize now that this is kinda,
it becomes to be challenging to control.
So you're really required to have
the right observability posture.
You really want your system to ping you
instead of you pulling the
system that's much more scalable.
When you approach observability,
at least in our experience with ECS,
you have several options.
The one that which is most
documented is, you know,
you spin up a sidecar on your services
and with FireLens
and then you scrape your
telemetry for example.
Still within the tag team
with AWS in the preserve engagement,
we decided to go with a different way,
which is a little bit more
exotic but it works for us
and I will present that to you.
Again, single VPC really talk
single PC multiple accounts.
One for red, no I mean some
for red nodes, some for QCUs.
Those accounts,
they basically publish their
logs in a serverless way
using CloudWatch and they also publish
the metrics if you turn
on container insights
in a serverless way into
CloudWatch metrics, right?
Each account does that.
What we did is connect what
is called log subscriptions
and metrics streams.
Those are basically some,
again serverless mechanisms which react
when a new log appears in cloud
watching, whichever account
or when a new metric appears
in whichever account.
They react, you can
connect them to Firehose,
or Kinesis and to a Lambda.
And what we do, we use those
which are in a single account
and we use those to send our telemetry
to our third party observability vendor.
That's for infrastructure
related telemetry.
For what concerns your
application telemetry.
What we did was deploying
an open telemetry collector
within the VPC we just discussed
spanning across accounts
in a dedicated cluster.
And this open telemetry collector
has been configured to autoscale.
What's bit different with,
you know, standard practice,
at least based on our experience
is that normally what you do,
you configure collectors
to scrape your services.
In this case, our services
are pushing to the collector.
So why that, no sidecars,
you don't have the problem
of monitoring the monitor.
You don't have the problem to decide
how much compute you need
to allocate for the sidecar
and you have one single point of entry
to control everything,
which looked easier to
us at the scale we were.
And again the telemetry collector.
The telemetry collector then
pushes through a private link
again back to our observability vendor,
which then holds everything.
You have log, you have metrics
and you have traces if you're using it.
All right, where next? We want more.
We want more and we are still growing,
but right now we're at a certain scale
where we cannot afford
any more to just grow without thinking.
So we need to adopt a
sustainable growth approach.
There is a lot of appetite in the market
and also by extrapolation in the firm
to leverage hardware accelerators,
GPUs, but not only GPUs.
As you might know when you use Fargate
you are limited to 120 gigs
as the top memory level you could choose.
Some application, our site
require more than that.
And so we are looking at alternatives
and the alternative spoiler alert is,
we are already testing and
looking at managed distances,
which looks really the sweet,
like the sweet spot
where we can adopt all these elements
and make our business grow
and our deployment grow.
Orthogonally this, we wanna keep
the resiliency posture we already have.
We increased it going multi account
and now we are starting to
think to go multi region,
'cause right now we were,
all the accounts were deployed,
I mean we're initialized
in a single region.
So we started to think how to do that
and take the unit.
I already discussed, you know,
the VPC unit with all the accounts,
take it and move it into another region,
have a multi-region deployment,
which will give us advantages
on flexibility for compute,
but also, you know, residency,
a high residency posture.
And that was it for me.
Thank you for your
attention. And back to Alex.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)